[Applause]
entering the race with his wife and two
daughters in tow rishi sunak opened his
campaign in margaret thatcher's hometown
of grantham
[Applause]
boris johnson's former chancellor
attempted to brand himself as the
underdog and said he would prioritize
reducing the nhs backlog criticizing his
opponents pledged to cut taxes that he
himself raised
the nhs will be safe in my hands
we face the worst nhs winter crisis in
decades
tackling the backlogs is the biggest
public service emergency
we need a fundamentally different
approach
we will take the best of our covered
response and apply those lessons to
clearing the massive backlogs in the nhs
speaking to party members in kent liz
trust steered the conversation back to
brexit we need to tackle the nhs backlog
and i would put in place a strong health
secretary that would get that done but
in order to pay for those public
services we need a growing economy
that's so vital that we unleash those
post-brexit opportunities
we get rid of those pointless eu
regulations and we also cut taxes to
make sure that we are
getting people to set up businesses and
help grow the economy
so far the battle for number 10 has been
fought largely on the economy but today
as the starting pistols were fired both
candidates are desperate to prove they
can do more than just be fiscally
responsible
mr sunak is vehemently against borrowing
his priority is to tackle inflation liz
trust on the other hand is pro-borrowing
post-pandemic because she's keen to
start cutting taxes in a dig to liz
trust rishi sunak said if the government
is to deliver on its brexit promises it
needs to be led by someone who believes
in brexit and voted for brexit both
candidates vow to review existing eu
laws retained after brexit
on health rishi sunak is planning to put
the nhs on a war footing and use lessons
learned from the kovid pandemic to clear
waiting lists liz trust says she's
committed to increased nhs funding
though there are questions over how she
would do this considering her plans to
cut taxes we're on a war footing but we
haven't got enough troops to fight the
battle and the battle is a long one this
is a long campaign that the nhs is going
to have to pursue now to bring down
waiting times
as boris johnson's final parliamentary
week as prime minister came to an end he
was out and about with ukrainian
soldiers training with the british army
[Applause]
shadowing soldiers boris johnson was
keen to show the government's unwavering
support for ukraine solidifying his
legacy as a prime minister who
unequivocally backed ukraine and stood
up to vladimir putin but that's not the
only battleground on boris johnson's
mind ballot papers for voting to replace
him go out in the next two weeks so his
potential successors need to make a good
impression on tory members very quickly
if they're going to win the top job mari
aurora sky news westminster